this is the front line of the
immigration war in America right now
that's Mexico the border tones are not a
place that you would want to come and
visit why are we going I don't want
people to not know how hard this
struggle is you want your baby to be
born in America the greatest place how
many people do you think you brought
over America thousands of people we call
Border Patrol's we put the camera down I
heard yesterday they deported an
eight-year-old Guatemalan girl and her
three kids twenty-one billion dollars to
build a wall right there I could do it
if I had to but on the bright side the
Olympic Mexican pole vaulting team is
number one in the world right now
people think United Airlines treats
their passengers Val we're never gonna
show up coke up your ass stuck in the
overhead compartment for a couple weeks
I went on tinder wait with somebody on
the other side of the wall that's the
biggest block in history Jeff Ross
roasts the border November 16th
Comedy Central damn this guy what are
you celebrating Cinco de Mayo neighs hey
everybody I'm Jeff Ross if you like what
you just watched
be sure to watch the actual special when
it airs Jeff Ross roasts the border
Comedy Central November 16 10:00 9:00
central assuming you're not deported by
this